when it comes to making movies actors
are just one small piece of a huge
puzzle between the writing the directing
the editing and the marketing there are
so many things that can go wrong that
it's no wonder stars occasionally think
their own movies are going to be total
bombs sometimes they're right but other
times stars have been shocked when their
films actually became huge hits instead
here's a look at some insanely
successful films that even their stars
didn't believe in the Terminator when
Arnold Schwarzenegger was offered the
title role in the 1984 sci-fi classic
The Terminator his agent told him it
would be the end of his career but
Schwarzenegger disagreed not because he
thought the movie was going to be good
but because he figured the film was so
low profile it wouldn't even register as
a blip on his career when it failed
Schwarzenegger remained just as negative
as he was gearing up to film the movie
telling a friend who inquired about a
strange pair of boots in his trailer on
the set of Conan the Destroyer that they
were from some movie I'm doing of course
the boots were part of his costume for
the Terminator you know the film that
made him a household name the full monty
if you've never seen The Full Monty
just imagine Magic Mike only filmed in a
bleak English city in the 90s and
instead of shredded American actors
start a bunch of English guys with dad
bods the film was a box-office smash
earned four Oscar nominations and is
consistently ranked as one of the
greatest British films ever made also
lead actor Robert Carlyle hated it why
well in an interview with talk-show
hosts Graham Norton Carlile explained
that the shoot was extremely hard and
that the first cut of the movie was so
bad executives planned to send it
straight to video it was a tough shoot
for months he was a tough shooter who
really didn't see hit written on the
Full Monty
luckily after the director was fired a
new editor was brought in who totally
recut the film resulting in the classic
version fans know and love nice it with
near Universal critical acclaim and
hundreds of millions of dollars made at
the box office it ranks among the most
critically and commercially successful
horror movies ever made and that was a
huge relief to star Bill skarsgård who
told variety he was convinced the whole
time the movie was going to fail saying
I just felt something really terrible
was going to happen to me personally or
the movie not because he thought it was
bad but because he thought things were
going too well
and he kept waiting for the other shoe
to drop it never did though and the
movie became one of the biggest smash
hits of 2017 Pirates of the Caribbean
nobody expected Pirates of the Caribbean
the curse of the Black Pearl to succeed
it was a pg-13 Disney pirate adventure
based on a theme park ride just for
starters
even Disney head honcho Michael Eisner
tried to shut production down when he
found out it was going to cost over 100
million dollars that probably was the
most difficult decision in my history on
committing to a movie Eisner wasn't
alone in his misgivings during a frank
interview with The Guardian in 2008
Keira Knightley confessed that most of
the principal cast were embarrassed to
be working on the movie it was really
embarrassing and we all thought it was
going to be total at Knightley never
told any of her friends she was working
on it which must have made for some fun
conversations after it turned out to be
a massive worldwide hit that spawned a
blockbuster franchise guardians of the
galaxy like many in Hollywood Chris
Pratt was pretty worried that the first
guardians of the galaxy movie was just
too weird to succeed
in fact both he and director James Gunn
admitted that they were pretty worried
that their careers would be over if as
pundits predicted the film turned out to
be Marvel's first bomb Pratt told The
Hollywood Reporter you don't make a
movie with a talking tree you don't
spend this much money on a raccoon with
a gun for me I was like oh so this
movie's gonna bomb done this is the end
of my career more than 700 million
dollars and a heap of critical praise
later Pratt was the face of a franchise
and Gunn was
of Hollywood's hottest writer directors
past the ammo trash pandas taken
released when Liam Neeson was in his
mid-50s taken somehow managed to take a
veteran actor known almost exclusively
for his roles in serious dramas and a
single Star Wars movie and established
him as an action star it turned out to
be a surprise box-office success that
spawned a film trilogy and TV spin-off
and nobody was more surprised than
Neeson himself during a visit to the
Late Late Show Neeson admitted that he'd
figured the film's plot of a man punches
half of Europe to find his daughter was
too basic to warrant a cinematic release
I just thought no one was
straight-to-video obviously it's simple
Neeson reportedly took the role of ex
CIA agent Brian Mills because he was
sure he'd never get another offer to do
an action movie considering his age
nearly a decade later he's still
whooping bad guy but Animal House
according to Hollywood lore during the
production of Animal House an executive
from Universal approached director John
Landis with a simple ultimatum find a
big-name star that could put on the
poster or the studio would pull the plug
luckily for Landis he just so happened
to be good friends with Donald
Sutherland who said he'd happily appear
in the movie for 250,000 dollars
the studio said no soul and has made a
counteroffer $25,000 for a single day's
work and 2% of the film's gross
Sutherland told Landis I just want the
money because he didn't think the movie
would succeed so a revised offer of
$35,000 was drawn up by his own
estimation turning down that initial two
percent offer cost Sutherland 14 million
dollars for a single day's work whoops
Star Wars even George Lucas the
mastermind behind the Star Wars
franchise wasn't so sure the film would
be a hit
shortly before Star Wars hit theaters in
1977 he visited the set of his friend
Steven Spielberg's new movie Close
Encounters of the Third Kind Lucas was
so impressed he became convinced Close
Encounters was going to blow Star Wars
away at the box office
Spielberg disagreed and offered up a
deal he would give Lucas 2.5 percent of
Close Encounters box office grow
in exchange for a 2.5 percent stake in
Star Wars
Lucas jumped at the deal and by some
estimates Spielberg ended up making
nearly forty million dollars as a result
now that turned out to be a pretty good
bet thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]